Good afternoon
Welcome everyone here
We have more than 400 people here.
There seems to be no space on campus.
Can accommodate all those who want to participate together
To this end, we have many video playback devices on campus.
It will receive the image of the presence and transmit it to the network.
therefore
Countless people will join us in this moment
My name is Randy. Bryan
I am the dean of the Computer Science Academy.
Returning from Randy back to Carnegie Mellon as a professor
By the time I was promoted to the dean last year.
I am very happy to work with Randy.
Randy passed away on July 25
Forty-seven years old
It’s a tragedy
We all miss him very much
And we will continue to miss him
But our main purpose today is to commemorate Randy
His life and his legacy
Special mention is
His influence on many people
Not only the people Carnegie Mellon knows
Or people who met on his life journey
And spread to the rest of the world through the Internet in the past year.
Those inspired by his story
Please turn off your mobile phone first.
You can't engage in any photography activities.
The puppets on the stage are donated by people.
of course
Randy is known for his interest in filling puppets
Although I think his interest lies in getting, not owning
These puppets will be donated to charity after the event.
You will also find the memorial on this occasion.
This is Irene
Of course this is the Tigger
Thank you all
When you think about Randy’s famous lines
"Selecting a side station: Tigger or Earl
I think I know exactly where I will stand.
I quote Randy's famous Irene and Tigger arguing
Of course, I am also a Tigger
Today we have a lot of speakers.
In order to prevent me from jumping up and down, I will introduce them one by one.
I will finish them all.
Then they will come to the stage to give a speech.
this is me
Next, I have something to say.
Andy is Randy's teaching professor at Brown University.
After reading Randy's entire book
I will know that he is called "Uncle of the Netherlands"
Jessica is a friend of his time at the Institute.
They have always been in good contact
And greatly helped Randy and his family last year.
Cope with all kinds of situations they must face
Dennis is a colleague at the University of Virginia.
Randy says he is an indispensable partner
They have completed many virtual reality projects together.
Dan is the director of the Human-Computer Interface Research Institute.
The unit is part of Carnegie Mellon University
Randy has also been involved in the past.
In many ways, that’s his home.
Dennis. Kaskov
I didn't want to mention this.
But he is mentioned in the "Last Speech" book.
The person who was calculus (c)
He was a student at the University of Virginia.
At that time, Randy was teaching there.
After that they still work together
Dennis is now the leader in Alice's program technology
Tang is the executive producer of the Entertainment Technology Center.
And what you need to know
Is the email address of Don
Jesse is also heavily involved in the entertainment technology center.
in every aspects
He played Randy’s role in the Entertainment Technology Center.
Jerry Cohen is the principal of the University
And he is also a very good friend of Randy.
At last
David is the first Christian church priest in Pittsburgh
Will be the end of the whole speech by him
I will make a small update for the "Last Speech".
Part of the speech was cut off on many YouTube videos.
But that part is a series of presentations.
Part of the cut is
Jerry got up and announced
Name a bridge in the name of Randy
This bridge is very symbolic
It is connected
New Computer Science Building under the name of Bill Gates
With the Purnell Art Center
The connection between the two buildings has already been planned
This makes it easier for students and people to cross the campus
Link the computer science building to the main part of the campus
It’s quite unbelievable to say.
The bridge is also connected
Randy has tried to combine two departments (CS & ART)
When principal Cohen announced the bridge last year
This is the look of the bridge.
Its previous construction progress is still in its early stages.
The potential of this imaginary map is much greater than the authenticity.
But now I just want to tell you what it looks like.
This bridge does exist now
Although it has not been built to allow people to walk on it
In the Gates Center in the Computer Science Building
The steel bone has been put on
You can climb the upper floor of the Gates Center
Watching how the bridge will be in the future
Link Computer Science Building and Purnell Art Center
Then you can imagine to
How many people will walk through the bridge every day?
In fact, Jerry talks about
Students after several generations
Will pass this bridge named after Randy
They will have the opportunity to meet Randy
And for us, he is so special
And this is why this bridge seems to have the characteristics of an artist.
Now you can see that the bridge already exists.
If you want to climb the fence
I should not tell you that you can do this.
Then you might as well take the bridge to the new building.
One year from now
This bridge will exist in reality
People will walk on this bridge
This will be a wonderful thing
I want to tell some of my own memories of Randy.
As I said
When he was a graduate student here
I don't know much about him.
But when he became a faculty member here
I am quite familiar with him.
I have to say this time with Randy.
Is an extraordinary journey
Especially his last speech in the last year.
For all of us
Randy’s life is a great experience.
So I thought a little bit about it.
What kind of characteristics is it?
Make him so extraordinary and outstanding
And make him a person so important to many people
So I came to the stage to introduce four points.
The first point
Randy’s inner life is always in childlike
And fully displayed
In The Last Lecture
He talked about his dream of chasing childhood
For example, playing with the National Football League
Play a role in Star Trek
And floating in space
When I heard him say this
My response to this matter is
I also recall my childhood dreams.
If I pursue my childhood dreams
I might become a vet or a racing designer.
I really appreciate Randy.
Have a childlike innocence in your life
Excited and inspired by things
Second point
He has a unique personality trait
Also has amazing ways of thinking strategically
Randy pursues his dream as a goal
And do what the average person can't do.
Whether it is to take the opportunity to take a "vomiting comet"
To announce his flight to the outside world
Or attract the attention of the dream lover Jie Yi
I don't know who else can stick like Randy.
He is setting goals and continuing to chase
Third point
He is an amazing risk bettor
Many times when people see that the results are not good
They become risk averse
Because they saw that when things didn’t go according to normal procedures
All bad results
But Randy has the ability to see the future and all possibilities
And see all the bad results
Then still go to adventure
I want to some extent
As he described
He does not regard mistakes as bad situations
Think of new things that can be learned and tried
Because of this
He can always stand up and accept the challenge
Even if it might not work
Let me take the example of starting an entertainment technology center.
Here he is a very successful professor
He is engaged in the study of virtual reality.
And very successful in teaching and popular
He does not take the road of the general staff
Instead, set up a master's degree with someone.
That person's email address is thedon@cmu.edu
That field did not exist at that time.
The entire education method has not been tested yet.
Of course it has been successful now.
This is also an example of his pursuit of goals.
Have the courage to stand up and take on such a huge risk
the last point
Randy generously uses his time and talent to help others.
Of course he has the ability to pursue the right things.
At the same time, he also has the ability to see things for others.
He will give generous advice to others very generously
Sometimes those people don’t really want those suggestions
But he will be honest, straightforward, and not showing a sense of superiority.
And don’t provide advice in a selfish way
Everyone thanked him
Think Randy is sincere
And calculate the situation that is most beneficial to you.
I am with many in Carnegie Mellon
Even people from other universities have talked
They talked about Randy sitting down and sharing the idea of ​​a successful teacher.
Help them overcome many problems
And then have a huge impact in their lives.
Randy is really incredible and generous in this regard.
I want to be in the past few years
We can all see from many different faces
He showed the world his advice to others.
So influential and inspiring
The above is a summary of some of my characteristics.
Now let us know about him.
The opportunity to speak with people who have worked with him for many years
thank you all
Miss Ladies, Good afternoon.
I am Andy.
I am very honored to be at Brown University.
Become Randy's guiding professor and friend
Open his teaching career and research career
And interactive graphics research
Can participate in the recollection of Randy’s incredible and stimulating life
For me
Is both sad but also profound glory
This is the favorite Randy photo of my life.
At that time, I was the head of the department.
I must personally award a diploma at the graduation ceremony.
Randy is looking forward to getting a diploma
But he got the Chinese menu.
You may ask, "Why?"
I often take my entire group of students out to eat Chinese food.
Randy, Mr. White Bread
I really don't like Chinese food.
He hates Chinese food very much.
He didn’t learn how to eat with chopsticks.
But he will still come anyway.
Because even if he is still just a college student
He also understands the importance of group interaction.
However, this picture always makes me scream
His piercing and uncontrollable laughter
And his ability to always turn any situation into a joke
Even if the joke happened to him
When Randy started studying at Brown University
Actually it is somewhat unstable
He performed very well on the introductory course.
But the university assistants suggested me
Don't hire him as a teaching assistant
Because they think Randy is a little arrogant and a bit arrogant.
Especially when you are with a newbie
His speech is too strong
Once I wisely overthrew the views of the assistants.
Because I was lucky to find
He is a piece of uncut jade
He has obvious talent and abundant ability
And this boy has repaid the grace of my knowledge.
He became an excellent teaching assistant
Then become the leader of the teaching assistant
The rest of his life is like what we say
Become history
He is in my graphic research team
Also an excellent university research assistant
In our hypermedia project
The part he is mainly responsible for
User interface for the most advanced illustration tools
When most people focus on the functional and performance aspects
But Randy has uniquely raised the concern of "user experience."
Make "user experience" a focus of attention
Established a perfect customizable viscosity (Note: the higher the viscosity, the lower the transfer)
This is the first time I saw something like this.
We will always remember the work ethics of his "good spirit"
And the fun he got from everything
Like making cool stuff we have never seen before.
In addition, this is also very important
He has the ability to have a perfect presentation
He is a master
He is very good at questioning and responding.
At least his questions and responses are well rehearsed.
Prompt role and humor on the spot
At that time, because he was very enthusiastic about helping students.
There are very talents and traits that are good at expression.
And creative in research
I keep persuading him to go to the Institute.
Get a Ph.D. that proves that you can teach
But when he arrived at Carnegie Mellon University
He was the same as when I was studying at the institute.
He often feels discouraged
Then he will call me
I wonder if the research is really worth it.
I keep talking to him.
How beautiful my life in the academic circle is.
Because I insist and get a degree
He just insists on sticking to me.
I feel that I have done some of the power
Hanging carrots in front of him to lure him forward
Help him stay in the entire academic circle
I want to share two letters he wrote to his college girlfriend.
At the time, his girlfriend was also a teaching assistant.
Then when it comes to the head of the teaching assistant
She is called Heidi.
Randy writes to her after the Disney holiday
And return to Carnegie Mellon University to teach
He wrote to tell her
"I feel that I have access to super rich resources."
"And this rich resource is the student team working with me."
Letter with instructions
"In many ways, I have become a young Andy."
"Besides those who dare not eat spicy food"
Needless to say
I am very proud of that lovely comment.
Next, I will show the letters.
Although you can't see clearly under the stage
But basically Randy talked about
Eighty-five dollars of speeding ticket
He talked about the reasons in the middle of the letter.
And claiming that "I am innocent"
And support him with some simple physics
In addition to visual computing
Draw the whole thing chart to the college girlfriend
By this matter
We can see Randy’s persuasive ability.
There are other parts in the letter.
But I didn't show it.
I am very happy to tell you now.
Brown University in recognition of Randy's outstanding contribution
And let the students of the university department
Can also experience these experiences that have a major impact on life.
And these experiences start with Randy.
Then passed on to the next generation
To students at Virginia and Carnegie Mellon University
Brown University is setting up
A summer research internship program donated by the outside world
We can be proud of the first announcement
"Randy Bowes University Summer Research Intern Program" has been established
Thanks to the generosity of the former Girl Scout leaders who honored Randy
I want to ask you some questions.
And will provide my answer
Why is Randy so amazing?
Why can he make more than just the people at this venue?
But people from any place resonate?
Why can he be the most famous computer scientist?
And become a global trend?
I believe that because people know
He is really a real hero
In an era with many traditional heroes
Especially like political leaders and sports stars
They all have one original form
of course
Randy does not fly
He is no greater than life.
But he has played his life to the fullest
Not through the madness in life
But through his enthusiasm and persistence
He did realize his dream
And provide us with the best example
I hope he can exist in our memory forever.
And continue to inspire us
thank you
Randy likes some props
I brought this little doll
Next I will tell you a story of him.
My name is Jessica.
When the Randy Institute was in the mid-1980s
I am one of his friends.
And in recent years
I am his colleague at Carnegie Mellon University.
The first time I met Randy was in 1983.
At the time, I was a prospective graduate student at Carnegie Mellon University.
And he is a first-year graduate student.
I am not sure if Shelen knows
The social importance of these visits
Many of the people she had inadvertently introduced to us at the time.
Still very good friends
A few of them are still married.
Randy and I later realized
We have something in common
We enter the institute not through the "regular" pipeline.
When he was first admitted to school
He came here to defend himself
I am because a friend helped me to say a few words.
And can be listed on the waiting list
Finally we all become
Professor of tenure at Carnegie Mellon University
Perhaps this also proves
Many admissions pipes are unknown.
I think Randy publicly acknowledged this for the first time.
In his "Last Speech"
As you know
Randy loves to use the to-do list
And do your own time management very well
Once he laughed at himself
He wrote "Get a tenure" on the to-do list.
This is really not a project that should appear on the to-do list.
But you may not know
He has considerable enthusiasm for getting a tenure.
He usually eats oatmeal for breakfast.
Mix about two-thirds of the water to eat
If we use a standard measuring cup with only one-third of the water
It takes two strokes to reach two-thirds of the amount.
And Randy is a cup that can find two-thirds of the water.
And save more than one step
Please don't mind if he will take several years to make up.
The time he spent looking for a measuring cup
Although he has great passion for time management
He is spending time on
Friends, students, colleagues are generous
He is the best consultant candidate
He will listen intently
And give you a clear and clear answer
His answer is not a decisive comment.
He put his most real thoughts into the answer
When his answer is impeccable due to the guarantee of academic logic
He will be very happy
During the research period
We are very serious
But compared to now
At that time, it seemed to be relatively free
In those days
TV shows of "Street Street Blues" will be broadcast every Thursday night.
We will gather in "Bucha Feder"
A house rented by Randy with his friend
Eating ice cream while watching the show
of course
This is a long time since the birth of TiVos.
But between watching TV shows and interspersed ads
We have more fun chatting with each other.
We also did a lot of parties.
And provide a lot of cheap food at the party.
Usually Italian pasta
Because it can fit into Randy’s small palette
Then we make a salad in the garbage bag.
Because we don't have a large enough container to hold the salad
Randy is very brave
His most heroic act is nothing more than
Always publicly announced to everyone
He has struggled with cancer in the past few years.
I am honored to help him.
Choose all feasible medical methods together
For his children
What I want to say is
If cured Randy's medical technology already exists
That will allow him to stay with the child.
And watch them grow up
We have already killed the disease.
Randy can no longer afford
Any pain in order to defeat the disease
But in the early days
He is very brave about many things.
His research direction has changed twice.
From the field of "database trading" in the postgraduate era
"Human Machine Interface" when you go to the University of Virginia
Finally, the "Entertainment Technology" field of the Entertainment Technology Center
Every transformation is not just a new field of research
It is also an academic field that is not widely accepted.
He is really very good at this.
Randy also bravely to his friends and recently to the world
Show that he cares the most
At the time of research
Randy will wear corduroy and flannel shirts
And his high school leather jacket work
This is a bit strange
Because most of us are busy forgetting
The embarrassing social situation in high school
But he is very proud of the leather jacket.
He feels comfortable in letting others know about it.
For us
We have passed the stage of laughing at him.
So we made this doll
Dressing Randy into his appearance at the Institute
Corduroy, flannel shirt, leather jacket
If this doll is recently made
Then it will wear Carnegie Mellon's POLO fir and khaki pants
As if he was a teacher
Walking in the Carnegie Mellon University building
Those who watched the "Street Street Blues" program together
On the fourth of July every summer
Will gather together and hold parties
Although we only held it once on the 4th of July
The first time was held in 1985
Notice that our clothes are quite fashionable
A few years later
We started to build the human flesh pyramid
We must be very good at this
Until someone started complaining
And started to make some mistakes
Then we thought that we could put the child to the top.
And reach the new height of the pyramid
This is our party photo for the summer of 2007
It happened to be known before Randy’s cancer recurred.
Absolutely no doubt
Randy is the catalyst for our annual party
We will continue to do it.
So we can tell his children
And remind yourself of the good and bad of the past.
Think of their father, our friend Randy
I have done the stupid things I have said.
thank you
Hello
I am Danny. Poft
I am from the University of Virginia.
I am an experimental psychologist.
Randy worked with me in the early 1990s.
Even if he returns to Carnegie Mellon University
We continue to cooperate
Until the last few years
more importantly
Randy is one of my very good friends.
When I first met Randy
On the basis of only knowing a few days
I will look at him
Then he will say his opinion
Then I will say, "What have you done?"
for example
He teaches a human-computer interaction
Or a human-machine interface
I said, "I am a psychologist."
"There are some buttons on the machine."
"Try to let the machine run out of the results with these buttons."
Hey~ I pressed the keyboard
We continue
Well, I am a psychologist.
I saw what Randy did.
So every time on the first day of the class
He will knock a video recorder with a big hammer
He will bring a video recorder
And explain how bad its interface is.
Then he will knock it out with a big hammer
And that’s how he started his first class.
In psychology
We will not do this
For me, get along with Randy.
I have to touch some people.
And to some extent
Become part of that professional community
If it weren’t for him, I wouldn’t touch it.
I have to know
People in the field of computer science and computer graphics
And Disney Dream Project, Microsoft, Intel
And found interesting things created by engineers
These are not easily accessible to psychologists.
I want to tell you a story.
It’s very special to make friends with people like Randy.
And interesting stories with him
In the early days
We started to participate in computer graphics seminars
Sometimes it will be like "perception basis"
Or a workshop such as virtual reality.
So we joined together
Computer Graphics Symposium in Orlando, Florida
one day later
I learned that there is no speech suitable for me.
For writing programs or graphics
I am a layman.
So I don't have to care so much.
Disneyland is really close to it
So I decided to go right away.
Because I have never been to
I want to take this opportunity.
Take a bus to Disneyland to play
And I really did it.
About an hour passed
I found out
Unless you are going to the Disney with the kids
Otherwise it is a meaningless place
I am staying alone.
After a day like the melancholy of Little Oyster
I returned to the seminar
I told Randy.
I don't understand why Disneyland is so attractive.
The next day I went to Disneyland with Randy.
I mentioned before
Through Randy, with childish eyes
Come to watch Disneyland
It’s so wonderful.
It's really wonderful
At the end of the day at Disneyland
Randy told me
Danny, fast, they are going to close!
We have to hurry
And this represents a special attraction.
The sweet spot of Disney World (note: the location that best understands the Disney essence)
Have a bridge
At the end of each day
Disney World will arrange a fireworks bridge
And Randy knows to stand there.
Is the best place to watch a fireworks show
We stood there watching the fireworks show
This is really wonderful.
I am really grateful to know Randy.
thank you all
Hi
I am Dan. Swatch
I am the director of the Human-Computer Interaction Institute.
I want to be from the point of view of the person in charge of the department.
To share Randy’s contribution to the Human-Computer Interaction Institute
One week before the opening of the "Last Speech"
Randy asked me for a photo of me.
I sent him a photo that didn't meet his needs.
Randy asked me for another photo.
I know that he must have his purpose in doing this.
In the course of the speech
Can be listed in Randy's slides of his bosses
See your photo
I am surprised and honored
But how did I become the owner of Randy?
I was about to quit at the time.
The position of director of the National Science Foundation Research Center
Randy entered my office
Then Randy asked me to say
Willing to take over the position of director of the Human-Computer Interaction Institute
As a trained electronic engineer
I used to design computers with some
Working with students from the Department of Computing
And there have been social scientists and cognitive psychologists.
And the idea that the designer works together
Tigger is disturbing in my heart
So I asked Randy.
Why does he think
I can be qualified as the director of the Human-Computer Interaction Institute.
Randy said
He is a member of the New Leaders Committee
Those research committees threatened him to say
If he does not find a leader candidate
Nalandi will be the leader
And Randy doesn't want that job.
So Randy is really honest enough.
I almost didn't wait for me to be ready.
Randy started to his new boss
Infusion time management principle
He does not want to attend the faculty meeting
But if there is a difficult job that I have to do
Just call Randy
He will help
in every aspects
When the leader of the department is a lonely job
Only a few people can explore new ideas with you.
Several times
I bothered him during Randy’s working hours.
I hope his assistance
I will send an email to Randy.
Ask him if he has time to talk to me
After a few hours
He will appear at my door
I will explain to him in my cognition.
This is a very complicated situation
Then he will make a simple summary
And showed his conclusion
His vision is very accurate in human behavior.
In the middle of his conversation
Randy will always stand at the door
Let us stay focused on each other
This is another dogma of his time management.
a dogma he believes in every day
In August 2006
One day Randy ran into my office.
He is carrying a laptop
And sitting at my conference table
I feel an unusual thing is about to happen.
Randy did not comply with his time management dogma
He told me that he had pancreatic cancer
Scanned
Cancer cells can be seen
Randy will come to my office regularly
Tell me the latest situation of the condition
His office description in August 2007
Especially I feel sad
But then
Randy is still holding
He will be a minority of hopes to survive
Randy is a good citizen forever.
When there is a problem with the faculty on the department
Will help fill the required funding gap
Randy is in his own medical problem
I thought about the plan that I didn’t need to support at all.
To support his research and salary
Randy is also very practical
He often humorously states his own grace.
So he won’t be too complacent.
In one communication
I told Randy
When I told someone about his story of pancreatic cancer
I feel great glory for him.
I never thought I would know one.
You can go to Oprah's talk show
Can also be on the cover of Parade magazine
Randy’s answer is
I should put my goal a little further.
This is of course how Andy teaches Randy how to reply to those
Has reached a set of responses from his standard students
Randy’s concern for her companions is amazing.
Surprisingly
When his cancer relapses again
And preparing his "final speech"
His family moved to a nearby Virginia home.
And manage his finances
Everything mentioned above
Are a full-time job
He sent me a few emails to confirm
If I didn't appear in the final speech
Will I be hurt because of this?
That kind of thought never appeared on me.
But it happened to Randy.
So when the faculty heard Randy’s cancer recurring
Many suggestions from different places
Spontaneously appeared
This also highlights Randy’s inspiring leadership
They decided to put "the third stage laboratory"
Renamed "Randy Bowt Lab"
This is Randy’s photo of the laboratory’s signature
This photo also appeared in the Last Lecture.
The word above is made by Sarah.
She is a professor at the Entertainment Technology Center.
The picture is provided by Reagan
He is an alumnus of the Entertainment Technology Center.
The sign was placed behind a mirror
So you have to see it through a piece of glass.
to conclude
Randy has a mysterious ability
Ability to translate complex problems into simple principles
And he will use some good-looking image stories.
To describe those principles
Randy called for
Those principles can be applied to all situations
I have a photo of him at my desk.
And I am looking forward to Randy
Tigger
Come visit me at any time.
I miss Randy very much.
And his wise advice
When I have a difficult problem to solve
I will ask myself
What does Randy say?
thank you all
Hello
I am Dennis. Kaskov
We pull back the time
Randy is a professor who just entered the University of Virginia.
very quickly
You can learn from the mouth of college students.
If you want to take Randy’s class
You have to make a thorough adjustment of your entire trip.
No matter what the prerequisites are
No matter what happens
You must reschedule your itinerary
You confirm that you want to go to the information structure he opened in the spring.
Or a lesson that his friend opened in the fall.
And this is for people
Should not cause much surprise
We have heard a lot of people applaud
He is a very great teacher
We have heard that he received the Good Teacher Award.
We have also heard about building virtual world courses.
This class will be handed over to students from outside the school.
Let me think a little more
Danny mentioned the famous 砸VCR event
I think Randy has the ability to attract people’s attention.
And can achieve a balance between teaching and attraction
So he has the ability to teach them
This is very admirable
You can see why he became famous.
This story is easy to tell
And it is a very good and great story
But his class is great
Not because of those eye-catching gimmicks
But the essence behind the class
Especially in "data structure" and "algorithm"
In the two lessons at a glance
For those who have not taken a computer science course
Algorithm is a very mathematical thing
There is a former Randy professor instructor.
You will be very surprised
Randy was arrested for teaching algorithms
But this is a necessary lesson
He still went to teach
He did
And this thing is really outside his comfort zone
The algorithmic course has no eye-catching way of attending classes.
There are no real objects visible
There is no graphic to attract people's attention to it.
For many people
It can be a boring lesson
Can also be a great course
This class is not just good.
But it’s great
This is the ins and outs of the whole thing.
you know
He made these things great and gorgeous
This is great
He deserves a lot of appreciation.
And this is really what he deserves.
The hidden meaning behind this is
He has the ability to find the most appropriate example in the algorithm.
As of today
My understanding of Huffman coding
Maybe more than what I have learned
That's because he raised the Italian parliament.
And how the parliament is formed into a perfect analogy
So now I understand
How does compression work?
Parliamentary government organization
And this is what I have learned.
you know
Just like in the 1980s
So if anyone is interested in this
I can talk to me afterwards.
I will be very happy to share this with you.
I think there is an analogy
Can be likened to "Randy is a great teacher"
And "How does he fight against pancreatic cancer?"
We all saw the "Last Speech"
How incredible is it to inspire people
And in an unimaginable coercion
Can also speak
And show people to himself
This minute he explained that the matter is coming to an end.
This is his death.
But in the next minute
He made us all laugh
How incredible this is.
How inspiring this is for people
How impressive his conversation is
What kind of speech is this?
How can you take him off?
I think
This thing has a greatness that exceeds our expectations.
And far-reaching effects
But I am not surprised that it has such influence.
We should be inspired by these words
And I think this will be his great heritage.
But for me
more importantly
I will remember the words behind them.
What kind of true meaning exists hidden
From the time I have known Randy for a long time
He has such virtues
Don't spend any time
Don't waste any moment
Don't say "Why me?"
It means "What is the problem, how can we solve it?"
Turn a corner
despite this
He doesn't have to do this.
I am referring to the matter of "knowing the problem and solving the problem"
If I can "handle the cold air in my rental house, I have to deal with it"
Can have the above ideas
It will be quite admirable
Everyday things in life are treated like this
But surprisingly
In the unfair to unbelievable pancreatic cancer
Still able to keep this idea
Even more surprising is
Behind this matter
He can still maintain amazing consistency
He got pancreatic cancer
Then immediately think with Jessica
How do you go next?
What is the best solution?
At a speed that is too fast
To proceed to the next countermeasure
He will say
"They clear the cancer cells just like removing the fish's internal organs."
"Everything will end safely"
"This will be my best chance."
"I will receive the strongest chemotherapy and radiation therapy."
"Because I only have the greatest chance to survive."
"And continue to live with my wife."
And he is not only concerned about this.
"I may die in this extremely dangerous operation."
"So I have to guide Caitlin's paper quickly."
"For her, because of my death"
"And she wants to complete the paper under such circumstances."
"How unfair this is."
Who would think so right?
He has such incredible ability
To keep his persistence
And what he did later
Has become his witness to persistence
When Plan A, Plan B, and Plan C fail
He can still be a week before the deadline
Thinking plan K and plan J
And think about something in his heart.
Just like a horror picture
Sitting in the study room with him
He seems to be a portrayal of strength
Continue to struggle
Care about you and your research team
And some negligible questions
He is there to help
I think this is why I always remember Randy.
"The most persistent thing about his persistence"
At last
This is actually not entirely surprising.
This is exactly what you expect Randy to do.
From knowing his deep and shallow
He will give different levels of feedback
But this does not make you less impressed
So why is this?
I will remember him forever.
thank you all
Hello
I am called Don.
I am building and guiding with Randy.
Carnegie Mellon University Entertainment Technology Center
For those who know me through Randy’s "Last Speech"
"Tornado" is a more widely known nickname for me.
Randy's speech
Built a lot of fame in the world for me.
Actually
My wife has dinner with me recently.
I was wearing a POLO shirt at the Entertainment Technology Center.
And noticed that the waiter is constantly aiming
Entertainment Technology Center logo in front of my shirt
He finally asked me finally.
Do you know Randy?
I nodded
From the "Last Speech"
I have been asked many times like this.
And explain how Randy created the Entertainment Technology Center with me.
While I am speaking
The waiter suddenly stepped back and shouted
"Oh! God!"
"You are the guy who made him live in hell for six years."
Without doubt
This will be the way to win a generous tip.
We will work together
Because Jerry’s principal thinks
The new field of entertainment technology is a
Compared with other separate fields
a broader field
I said those geniuses.
John Lassat
Ed Katemore, Steve Jabbers
And a few other people
They are not willing to move to Pittsburgh.
So in addition to a group of people with sincere desire
a technical barrier between technology and art
Breakthrough computer scientists gathered together
but me
a professor of drama
Boldly toward a place where there is no drama at all
School of Computer Science
I am trying to learn from there.
Interactive entertainment behind this amazing new world
It is called video game
First encounter Randy
Not because of personal factors
But because I participated in the "Building a Virtual World Show"
To tell the truth
I was confused about the "Building a Virtual World Show".
I am from the theater
A show is everything
When I first saw the construction of a virtual world show
I think it is still more like
Spring Carnival Funny Short Play Collection
Honestly
I couldn’t understand the true meaning of it at that time.
I often secretly yelled in my heart.
Is this a student at Carnegie Mellon University?
An extraordinary show that must be watched at the end of the semester
Why is such an amateur funny short play, essay
And technical hodgepodge
For many students
Is it the climax of their entire semester?
After pondering
I went on to understand
In fact, after so many years
Building a virtual world is a combination of technology
And the vision created through interactivity
To understand the stage of imagination
This impression is in my visit
The third stage of the Wean building
More enhanced
Unlike a monotonous lab
I saw a real, multicolored, spatial lighting
And a toy kingdom filled with stuffed toys everywhere
And the most important
Committed to enabling students to learn while playing
This achievement is worthy of respect
This respect is also mentioned by Randy in the "Last Speech"
And get approval
He and I are very different in many ways.
Although we have similar places in many other ways
This will be mentioned later
We are all tough guys
We are not people who will retreat
So Jerry wants us to be together
This is called the Entertainment Technology Center.
The colleagues inside are betting
Who will I be with Randy first?
One of the three rivers in Pittsburgh
I found out that Randy is intimidating.
But that is not his fault.
Randy has some
I think the qualities I need when I grow up as adults
I mean
His tall man
Brunette, handsome, healthy, outstanding, masculine
And attractive scientists
Dress up and join the look of the beach boy
Instead of being a professor in the Department of Computer Science
For me, when I have these qualities
Randy is a standard American
but me
relatively
Is a mature
American-born Liberian from Brooklyn, New York
a lifetime actor
In addition to having a theater, history, literature
And a critical doctoral degree
Dressed up like an overweight Italian
Or the mafia killer
Especially for computer scientists
Randy is a real sense of humor and good at expressing
a man of good demeanor and dare to dream
He is so straightforward and beneficial to people.
As a member of the world's human race
It’s hard to see people like this
In my growing up of Brooklyn or Miami
It is absolutely invisible
He does not smoke
do not drink
At most, it is a polite drink.
He will not be caught by him.
He is a real workaholic
Even if he is not qualified enough to get overtime pay
He also has incredible attention to health.
Really exercise in the gym every day
Playing team sports
Avoid spicy food
Italian salami, Italian cooked meat and ham are not cut
Never listen to rock music
Never figured out to participate
Drug research that makes people feel happy
And proud to be a blindly optimistic person
Boasting to everyone at the same time
He is a tigger rather than an eel
Trust me
Bensonhurst in Brooklyn
Is a claim that no one will be proud
I am a tigger
Tigger is named after the syllable of the drive (tigger, trigger)
It is one when you walk on the 14th Street
Read aloud the words that people will erect
This guy is an eagle scout
I am looking forward to his flying wings.
For me
The real finale is
I know that Randy eats the same thing every day in Chinese food.
White noodles wrapped in a layer of mayonnaise
With turkey
Shortly after we first met
I told him that
Other unique one
I know people who eat the same thing every day at lunch.
Is my wife
This sign is somewhat disturbing
Because my wife and I are the best witnesses of the opposite sex.
This seems to explain
Randy and I will not only work together
And also because of the entertainment technology center
Professional marriage (meaning cooperation)
And it happened too
Randy and I soon became "twin" movies.
Carnegie Mellon version of Arnold Schwarzenegger and Danny
But this is a new field of interactive entertainment.
Need a combination of art and technology
Randy and I learned
We must be the first model
If he and I can overcome the difference between us
And work together
Then we have a good chance to see
Software that truly embodies leadership and educational implications
It can create new processes, new tools
And a new vision for storytelling, entertainment and education
So today I am here to appeal to everyone.
We can't let Randy die.
The worst thing in my estimation is
Randy's wisdom and his life story
Will be forgotten on New Year's Eve
Or discard it after three weeks of doing what Randy said.
If it is so long, it will be fine.
for example
Allow your child to draw in his own room
Is the best example
But this is just a relationship in life.
A small step in caring, caring, respecting and sharing experiences
in other words
Randy’s life values
Honestly
In our country
Parents are allowed to draw in the room and be educated
This fact needs to be watched
An essential component of a great story
A truly great story with great appeal
Is the protagonist and hero of the story.
Got some conversions
a journey that will change lives
Or the main conversion of adventure
For those who know Randy or work with Randy
a hot professor
University life full of fun
And the pursuit of Jie Yi
Their marriage
And Randy becomes a super family man
Randy in the process
The changes experienced are unquestionable
How to play Jie Yi’s husband
Dylan, Logan and Chloe's father
Is his most famous
Talking about love
Before with Jie Yi, family
Randy is not the person who hangs "love" all day long.
Maybe he needs to love his job.
But this love will never be more than their entry into his life.
Such deep and meaningful
In my estimate
Randy’s most eloquent words are
He said at the Carnegie Mellon University graduation ceremony this year.
When he mentioned
He waited until he was thirty-nine years old to get married.
Because it takes so long
Can find one
People who are more important than their own happiness
This is a very touching confession
This is a confession of wisdom and truth.
Can constitute a degree of self-realization
Sufficient to prove
He has not been white in this life.
For human well-being
He also did his best
Randy wants us to find
Is there a person whose happiness is more important than happiness?
In fact, this is to tell us in his way.
We have to think for others
Everyone who thinks for themselves
Will walk into the dead end
This is the limit of arrogance failure
and so
The origins of the Carnegie Mellon University Entertainment Technology Center
Randy-Comet
And a trip to Tang-Tornado
When Randy used his extraordinary light
As well as insight, knowledge, fatherly advice
Crystal particle tail with wisdom
To illustrate the so-called paradise
I will continue to look for confirmation.
The paradise he believes is evidence of non-existence
Randy never likes to discuss or argue
Things about religion or supernatural powers
And these are things that I totally believe.
Actually
It is my fascination with human beings.
But there is a heavenly and spiritual level.
That is, Randy is indeed deep inside me.
Changed me profoundly
deep in the heart
He elaborated an intrinsic dimension
Make me think again
I think that I already know the knowledge, information, causality
And let everyone's life
Live faster and more fulfilling meaning
Yes
Randy
I
a short accomplice
Loudly and clearly heard
Because this morning
Early morning
I went to buy an Apple computer.
My signing is poor
So I have to be behind Don.
I am called Jesse. Shel
I first met Randy in 1995.
When I was working in the Disney Dream Project
I was a new person at the time.
I just got a job for about three weeks.
But my boss John
Call me into his office and tell me
listen
There is a university professor coming
And dangle in our studio
It’s a bit of observation
I want you to do a few things.
the first
I want you to give him anything he might need.
Technical support, collecting information, etc.
second
Make sure he doesn't get any trouble
For people who know Randy
You may guess
These two things are more difficult to engage in
From now to now
Few people mentioned that Randy likes to give others straightforward advice.
Whether you believe it or not
Many people who have been in Hollywood for 30 years
Not necessarily ready to listen to a university professor
Give them straightforward advice on how to improve the process
So I am a little bit helping him.
Learn about some of Disney’s policies
And he also learned very quickly
Then we start working
What we have to do is
In Florida
There is a virtual reality experience that builds the Aladdin Magic Blanket.
Randy wants to study very much.
Because he is very fascinated by how it works.
And my job is to help him.
So that we can collect data from it.
And this amount of information is really big.
You didn't get it wrong
This is something in 1995
We have collected several megabytes of data.
Every little trick on everyone
Have been recorded
We must reinvent the system built in Florida.
We want to make sure it doesn't break
And it won't suffer any damage to performance
That is a big project
I have to write all the programs
And I am not sure if this will work.
I told Randy
We don't have much time
This is not easy
If you messed up, there will be big trouble.
And I don't know if I can do it.
He just watched me tell me
"Do you know, you can do more than you think."
He is right
I work very hard
We are very focused on this matter.
And finally completed the construction
We have completed and collected a lot of information
Later became the material in his outstanding paper
When he left
We still keep in touch
to me
He is like a spiritual teacher
Even if we are not a partner at work
For many people
Randy plays the spiritual teacher in this way.
We often chat and discuss many things together.
After a while he said
"I hope that you can come to the Imaging Annual Conference to give a speech."
I said, "I? Go to the Video Academic Annual Conference?"
"I don't know, the Image Academic Annual Meeting feels very badly bullied."
"I don't know what I can do to make people feel good."
"I don't know if I can make them interested and impressed."
He told me again
"You can do more than you think."
So I went and gave a speech.
What surprised me was that this speech was very successful.
quickly
I became a frequent guest at the Image Academic Annual Conference and other seminars.
I am very grateful for his encouragement to me.
After a few years
We started talking about
Is it possible for me to teach at Carnegie Mellon University?
I really want Carnegie Mellon to teach.
But I said again: "I am not sure!"
"Do you think I can really help those students?"
Then he said
"Yes, you can do more than you think."
After that, I came here to teach.
A publisher has contacted me and said
"We hope to ask you to write a textbook about game design."
I think
It sounds very exciting
But I never wrote a book.
I don't know how to write
I started talking to other people about this.
Then I talked to Randy about this.
I said, "What do you think about this?"
"I am not sure, I don't seem to be suitable for writing books."
Then he said, "You still don't understand it until now?"
"You can do more than you think!"
And when my students are
Whether they can complete the project and feel confident
This sentence is always with me.
I will think of Randy and tell them
"You can do more than you think."
Tiger father has no dogs, they have completed the project.
to some extent
I regard this sentence as the philosophy of Randy in the nut.
There is no doubt that
This is his philosophy of life.
I think
Thanks for the "Last Speech"
It expresses intimate messages to family and friends.
Eventually moved many people around the world
And care about their relatives and friends
The Last Speech will be ours
Witness to "Man who can do more than I imagine"
Thank you Randy
Thank you for your challenge to me.
Thank you for challenging us all.
I am called Jerry.
I am the principal of Carnegie Mellon University.
Randy was in my eleven years as president
Come to me twice
Both are his own
We will meet regularly
To update my news about the Entertainment Technology Center
The first time I met was ten years ago.
This gives me a chance to correct this record.
Tang gave you an impression
Is the principal of the university
Sitting in his office and saying
"We need to design a master's degree in video games."
"And I know that two people can do this."
Things are not like this.
At the time, this meeting was on my calendar.
Tang and Randy, Drama and Computer Science
Aroused my interest
They came to my meeting room
And give me the ball directly.
"What we want is to design a master's degree in video games."
"But please don't worry."
"We will name it entertainment technology."
"No one will know its real name."
"You must find space and find money."
Actually
When they learned that they could not find financial support
They said, "Don't worry, we will find a way to get it running."
"Can we continue to do it?"
I said, "Of course, why not?"
To the day of his death
Randy will tell me
"I am a lucky guy."
"Being crazy in college"
"Put people like Tang and me to do these things."
Randy’s second visit was two years ago.
That day is September 11, 2006.
I went to the waiting room and wanted to greet him.
Like everyone who knows Randy
My relationship with him is based on jokes.
He is very thin
I said, "God, it seems that you are in good shape."
"It's like your youth in high school."
He came in to my office and said
"I am getting dying because of cancer. I have cancer."
Those who have seen his "The Last Speech"
I know what he did.
He fell to the ground
And began to make a push to stand up
Just like what Dennis said before.
Randy uses his remaining time
Come to me to make sure everything goes well
Alice’s plan is going smoothly
Entertainment Technology Center will continue to operate
I tried to tell him
"Randy, what can we do for you?"
Randy: "No, no, no, Alice plans will continue to do it."
"Don't worry about the Entertainment Technology Center."
This is a very classic Randy
That was what he said on the same day of the "Last Speech" a year ago.
You all know
Many people mentioned
It really touched thousands of people
He and Jeff
A book written by our alumni in 1980
Sold four million copies
Translated into 36 languages
Randy took the Oprah show twice, BBC News
And special reports from the Entertainment Technology Center
When you ask Randy why do this?
Is the most concerned thing for all media
He quickly gave an answer
There are two reasons
the first
Let the world know this horrible disease - pancreatic cancer
Second point
Because he loves Carnegie Mellon University
He is not shy to promote Carnegie Mellon University.
Only Randy can be his way
Promote Carnegie Mellon University
I am employed to promote Carnegie Mellon University
For his promotion
I feel ashamed of myself.
He loves Carnegie Mellon
Talking about love
I want to talk about it again.
For Randy
"Love" is a word with special meaning
I don't think he has any advice from Don.
And often put that word on the lips
I am not talking about the status of Carnegie Mellon University.
Equal to Jieyi and his children
Please don't misunderstand me.
But he really loves this place
you know
I received many condolences after Randy’s death.
I have received letters from many friends and relatives.
I also received letters from many people I don’t know.
They only know that I am the principal of Carnegie Mellon University.
I met people on the street.
They expressed their condolences to me.
This really makes sense
Part of the reason is of course because
Want to convey their grief to those who are willing to receive
That is, I am mourning together.
But I also learned from it.
When Randy passed away
Carnegie Mellon University lost a very important treasure
He is a good professor and a good teacher.
Good scholar, good colleague, good friend
But Randy wants a different way.
Come to Glory Carnegie Mellon University
For him after the "Last Speech"
In the last few months of life
Unscrupulous promotion of Carnegie Mellon University
We owe him a lot
The purpose of his doing so
It is his understanding of Carnegie Mellon University.
This is an allowable professor
Do the places where he used to do crazy things.
One can make people like Randy rise
And let the world know the environment
For this we will always be grateful
Tang is right
We can't let Randy die.
Can't let Randy's heritage disappear
We will do everything we can to pass on everything
This may not be appropriate
But this bridge
Is our hope
a building that everyone walks through every day
I dare say
Because of its location
It will have hundreds of people walking by
I want everyone to understand clearly.
This is not my idea
I am just honored to be at the end of the Final Speech.
Announce the news
This is Randy. Brian's idea
a great idea
We told the architect of the Gates Center Building
Thinking about how to build a
Can show the basis of the Randy concept
And to the world, everyone passing the bridge
Or people who watch in the distance convey such ideas
We are very lucky to have
a top architect, McKekin
He is definitely a very good and very sensitive person.
He is very concerned about this case
And also very concerned about Randy
He read Randy's article
He seriously realized the inheritance given by Randy.
Extremely concerned
And put these heritages in his design philosophy
And show the spirit of Randy
I show you his idea for you.
The origin of his design is out of
Chapter 39 of the Final Speech
"Don't be afraid to be the first penguin"
In this chapter, Randy talks about
He prefers glorious failure
He created an award in the Construction Virtual Reality class.
Give those plans the most daring
But the students who ultimately failed
"The first penguin"
Because as you know
The biggest challenge for penguins is
When they want to forage
They must jump into the water with carnivores
Who can escape the carnivorous animal
Be the first penguin to find food?
This is the concept of the first penguin award.
And the starting point of Mack Scodin's conception
He uses this metaphor
The same idea
The first brave penguin jumped into the water
And gradually integrate it into the foundation of the design
This design still expresses the concept of penguins
And at the same time, the sea they are immersed in
And this will be what you saw on Randy Bosh Bridge.
The side panels
This is a view from the center of Purnell.
You can see these side panels
obviously
He completely integrated the idea into the building
And let you know what his philosophy is.
Base of the bridge
Walking inside will also get the same idea
Looking towards the Gates Building
The bridge will be lit
For it there will be a lot of LED bulbs on the bridge
We are very happy
These are specially designed LED bulbs
Provided by Color Kinetics
Now part of the Philips company
Is a group of companies founded by Carnegie Mellon University alumni
So it is especially meaningful to us.
Will also be taught by the Academy of Drama in the field of lighting
To interpret the ideas to be expressed
And these bulbs will be controllable through the program
If you understand the idea of ​​these lighting
It can show unlimited changes through the program
Students can also write programs
Watch on the bridge or from a distance
Will be quite extraordinary
Yes
At the end of the bridge we will have brick walls
We won't use other ways to present
This will be another key topic
Of course this is what Randy found.
I talked at the end of the "Last Speech"
There will be several generations of students
Came to Carnegie Mellon University
They don’t know Randy
There is no way to know Randy.
And this bridge
Let them know
There is an amazing person among us.
Randy Bowsch
Let them know the whole picture of things
Also inspired them to understand
The meaning of Randy's inheritance
When they ask
We will tell them
I am called David. Helden
I am a pastor of the First Christian Church in Pittsburgh.
I am very honored to host
The wedding of Jie Yi and Randy on May 20, 2000
after that
Sometimes I will welcome them as a member of the church.
Sharing the joy of their child's birth
And grateful
Observing them with other community members
Develop a permanent sense of community
Two years with Randy’s condition
My mood is ups and downs
I do my best to help him with Jie Yi.
Last July
I am honored to be in Chesapeake, Virginia.
Hosting Randy's funeral
I will talk about it next.
What I heard in Randy's "Last Speech"
Somehow
I heard him say
Try to find out
For things that are inescapable, limited, fleeting
And the conditions under which humans will die
The most creative and rewarding solution
Those creative and rewarding solutions
Will highlight yourself
And what can you do?
You may only have 35 years
Respond to the dilemma of life with creativity and profitability
But there may be 95 years
Or less time
But a creative and rewarding response
Better than a good life
Also better than the fragment of incompleteness
These clips often upset our good life
These creative and rewarding responses
Will need a good life for a lifetime to brew
And these wonderful moments
Interdependent in a deliberate and open manner
This is the inheritance I heard from Randy.
Perhaps this is the highest compliment that can be expressed to Randy.
We will give Randy a living testimony forever.
By living
I mean our survival to a certain extent
Reflecting the message that Randy wants to pass on
I am not suggesting you.
Accepted his message without criticism
I am not saying these messages.
Will be intertwined with other wisdom
But if Randy’s message is to take us to
a higher level of mindfulness and imagery
That watery acceptance
Will not be able to keep his heritage forever
It’s really a reminder to myself and an ambition
Is to keep his message in mind
Really increase the moment of good life in life
Is our highest tribute to Randy
Holding such a spirit
I am willing to share with you
Those who adapted their self-colleague Dennis Hamilton
Spread hands today
Kindly show us it
Everyone here is taking time to come here.
Everyone here is also getting help.
We still have time
Tell our love to our loved ones
Apologize to those we have offended
We still have time to look up at the clouds in the sky
Sight catching the sky with birds
And watch the sun sink into the woods in the evening
We still have time
Bring our pain to the relief
And find the complete peace in there.
We still have time to extend our hands
We still have time to stretch our hearts
We still have time to face in the mirror
Our face is our sorrow and our freedom
We still have time to sing
We still have time to pray, plan and build
We still have time to love
We still have time
Because we all took the time
Because we all get help
We still have time
Maybe it can be said
Can make your personality more like a Tigger
So we have to make good use of our time
I will invite all of us.
Stand up together for this blessing
We all live in a profound and eternal mystery
With a simple heart
We bowed our heads in front of the veil
This veil blocks us and the people we love.
When we remember our love
And give the final farewell
Let us fearless
Let us transcend sentiment with love
Let us be confident
And believe that life is full of meaning and goals.
Even after death
Human life is sacred
His birth is sacred
His years are sacred
And his dying is also sacred
May peace be able to pass on good solutions
May peace be accompanied by
Accept the facts and grateful heart
Supreme soul
Will resolve the growing pressure on the planet
And will always exist in our hearts
Not only today
But forever
please sit down
Randy's family, friends, colleagues
By the inheritance of his legacy
And become closer because of his passing relationship
This range starts from a few small things.
Full letter in the mailbox basket
Lots of emails
These people who have sent letters have never seen Randy himself.
despite this
They used letters to indicate the legacy of Randy’s legacy.
How profoundly they affect them
Two big things
Painting on the railing or on the bridge
And scholarships and awards established in the name of Randy
In the past year
Randy is also recognized on many different types of awards.
Also includes his professional colleagues
He became a leading organization in information science
Researcher at the American Computer Association
He obtained the American Computer Society
Karl V. Karlstrom Distinguished Educator Award
Pittsburgh City Announces
November 9th, 2007 is the day of Dr. Randy
Randy is also listed as a magazine by American Times.
One of the world's most influential people
of course
Last year was an extraordinary journey for each of us.
Watching the message from Randy
Such as his speech film
Or his books
And the great success he brings
Let us continue to remember him for many years.
Thank you very much
Translation team: Chen Kunyu, Wei Zhaoyan, Wang Fangqi, Su Hanni, Xie Peiyao Subtitle: Yang Feiyu